hey guy how's it going man good man how
are you good so my name is Vincent nya
I've run a company that's a two choice
voting platform okay with photos videos
music and the question that I have for
you today is like we would get some
traction with like millennial kids and
we signed a boy band and so like the
kids are taken over the platform is
really use it in and asking lots of
questions about the you know the band
and stuff like that the question that I
have is like how how how do we take a
how do we leverage the fans that are
like on about this particular band and
try to turn it into you know them asking
questions about the other stuff that's
happening on the site does that make
sense like yeah and I think the answer
is you don't what wait what you're
trying to do is say oh we've all these
users that ask about this boy band if we
can get them to ask questions about
other things we'll have a bigger network
right the problem is the more you try to
force them to do something they don't
want to do the less likely they'll come
back at all and so what you need to do
is create more parallel paths of
interest and replicate what happened
with the boy band with a chef with you
know wine guy with an arc like you you
can't take a group that's interested in
something and make them interested in
other subject matter they're not yours
to make interest they're borrowing you
got it they're not yours I love when all
my startups think that they're their
users they're not their users they're
your product is theirs to borrow and so
you have to respect them and so what
you're doing is such a classic mistake
in mentality of oK we've got this now
let's take these people and make it good
for us by making them do other things
instead of making what they're there for
even better for them so they stay longer